Sandy wollen wir mal ein bisschen
Schwung jetzt hier reinbringen ich baue
ab die lernt schnell die Frau S ich
würde jetzt mal den Creeper holen
[Musik]
ne bist du
bereit okay er ist
da oh der hat ja echt oh
oh
Mist Sandra ja
Diamanten ja sagst du nichts Laser ich
das das doch klar dass ich das finde s
wo ist der Diamant schon in der Kiste
ich bin in der Kiste da ist keiner hier
Rechte h du hast ihn geklaut ich habe
kein
Diamanten ich find aber wir gehen
mittlerwe mittlerweile schon relativ gut
vor eigentlich in diesem
Projekt na ja du bist gestorben gerade
das Ziel des Spiels ist es Leute wir
haben nicht so wie bei Skyblock
irgendwelche Aufgaben die wir machen
müssen
sondern das einzige Ziel was wir haben
ist quasi ins Ende zu kommen richtig und
das Ende ist
ne
nee nee nee was denn das Ende ist das
mit dem Enderdrachen ja war der da Nein
diger Block ab oh mein Gott gleich kommt
wieder ein
Creeper was machen wir wie sollen wir
jetzt vorgehen bei einem Creeper okay
ich habe eine Idee wir bauen hier das
alles ab
s die Achtung ich bau das hier kurz ab
hier DF jetzt kein
[Musik]
Block dein er töte sie mit commands nein
Leute heute wird nicht getötet aber es
wird jetzt geprankt ich habe nämlich
nochine oh mein Gott ich bin tot was ich
bin tot warum ist riesen Monster gespt
sag mal wo bist
[Musik]
du wo bist du ich
erledige unten was ich bin im W unten
was ist ist das da noch ja
[Musik]
tot gleich müsste im Chat angezeigt
werden dass ich tot bin ich bin tot 3
€ 3 € N mich getötet nein wenn du so
fakest
nein guck mal wer da
ist
scheiße
he wieso stirbt
[Musik]
der weil es
regnet wegen Wasser lol haben wir ein
Glück was passiert oh mein Gott haben
wir ein Pech oh mein Gott haben wir ein
Glück was ist denn passiert Leute gar
nichts Sandy alles gut ist nichts
passiert
gerade ah guck mal s wir sind im Winter
total wir haben 29 Setzlinge eigentlich
brauchen wir eine riesen
Baumfarm ja gut so kommen wir so können
wir uns wenigstens gleich zwei Mini
holzütten bauen ja würde ich auch sagen
D lass uns auf jeden Fall ein Weg rüber
bauen dass wir wissen oder wir machen
halt beide so ganz kleine Häuschen ja
weil brauchen eh nichts Großes ja nur
unser Bett am besten immer so ein
bisschen durchswitchen oder
[Musik]
Leute
okay
Eismann so Leute ich
bra kann es sein dass du dumm bist also
soll ich dir mal ganz kurz sagen was ich
mir so gedacht habe ich finde durch
diese App lerne ich viel besser zu bauen
durch welche App durch die hier die
Mock ja das muss man als Anfänger als er
spielen find ich muss ich alles selber
neu craften und beim anderen war ja
schon so viel da weißt du ja aber das
ist ja eigentlich dann schwieriger wenn
du nicht so viel hast jetzt haben wir
Sandras Insel quasi hier kann Sandra
bauen was sie möchte da kannst du machen
was du willst kannst dir einzuen wie du
willst bauen wie du willst was auch
immer ich ma mir das gleich jetzt auf
anderen Seite h oh Hund oh das ist gut
den hole ich mir
direkt ich hab Hund
kleiner guck mal der Hund geht jetzt
drauf ne der H mach gar
NS Leute wie mache ich mir noch mal
Stöcker h macht gar nich Hund geht da
drauf
nein jetzt attackiert der Eismann hat
uns
[Applaus]
der ich che nicht alle wollen uns
verlassen noch ein Hund willst du den
haben ja hier ich habe die Knochen
zugeschmissen einfach rechtsg auf den
den Hund hier der nicht am sitzen ist
ein paar Sekunden
später warum schlägst du ihn denn mit
rechts natürlich mit rechts jetzt tötet
er
dich das bringt n musst du musst dich
einmal töten lassen damit der normal ist
wieder der hat rote Augen ja du musst
neben den und dich töten lassen damit
der wieder klar
kommt sehr gut Laa aber gib mir alle
meine Zäune diger die hatten nur Sachen
von
[Musik]
mirelet du hast dir diese okay ich gebe
dir die Sachen aber du hast dir niemals
ein Eisenschwert z.B selbst gecraftet
das ist von
mir das auch nicht die lügt den ganzen
Tag ne ich kenne kein Mensch GL so viel
lügt wie Sandra das ist so gelogen lass
mal kurz
überlegen
warte
kurz noch mal gerechnet nein wo das
scha ich hab es nicht Luca ich habe
nichts umgebracht wenn ich dir das do
sage dann ist es die Wahrheit der Hund
unsere Hunde sitzen hier beide die
können gar nichts töten aber der eine
Hund guckt do schon die ganze Zeit so in
die Ecke vielleicht war es
doch der weiß ganz genau dass der das
war wer von den beiden scharf
umgebracht wie guck wer war wohl ich
habe gar NS
gemacht ich checke hier gerade gar
nichts mehr ist unser Bett Weg Sandra
nee meins ist doch da und wo ist meins
hier unter Baum und wo ist deins schon
guck mal bei mir in der Ecke in meiner
Wohnung ach so das habe ich gerade nicht
gesehen nein das ist weg
ich habe es aber schon abgebaut ah okay
okay Laser ich würde sagen wir beenden
den Stream jetzt bei bei den Holzkisten
ja also Leute das haben wir jetzt alles
schon geschafft im ersten Teil hier ich
bin sehr sehr stolz auf uns ich unmal
diger nice so zum Abschluss noch mal
hier für
[Musik]
euch
tschüss
[Musik]